welcome back
it's time for drew's news your daily
slurp of those good news noodles and
with me at the desk is a man i'm the
lady in the [ __ ] with
anytime everybody
which one of i
are you lady or the [ __ ] uh it depends
on the day i think yeah
well actually speaking of a lady yes
every night before we rest our head on
that sweet pillow we all have our
favorite bedtime rituals well charlotte
tilbury the mega famous makeup artist to
the stars just revealed her show of
hands who knows who charlotte tilbury is
got it okay insider reports that before
bed charlotte takes off her makeup and
then reapplies
her mascara and eyeliner
she calls it her bedroom eye and after
seven years of marriage her husband has
never seen her without it what
she says she keeps it keeps the magic
alive okay
i think this is very sweet of of her you
know i think i like the intention which
is you know you want to be the best
version of you for your partner but
you're doing all that before you go to
bed what do you look like when you wake
up right is it just all smeared and how
much time are you spending washing your
pillowcases girl take a day off
this is too much
well we've got someone in the audience
who's uh put on makeup to go to bed
gabrielle
oh hi
okay so you do this hydro so hear me out
here okay when you're at the start of a
relationship
you know you want to look your best when
you wake up in the morning so
i'll wear my makeup to bed
in hopes that the next day it'll still
be just as fresh and cute usually not
but yeah still aren't you a little
smeary when you wake up definitely i
mean it's definitely not how i started
the night um the next morning but
you know you still feel a little bit
makeup still a little bit more you know
i've lost that loving feeling uh as the
song goes i need to let my skin breathe
i wear a lot of makeup i have a company
called flower beauty so we're always
testing
so i need to have my like no makeup
moments so that i can let my skin
breathe and heal because i'm always
playing with makeup i am obsessed i will
not go to bed without removing my makeup
if i woke up with my makeup something
really wrong
um i am like the obsessive face washer
um
but
those few times maybe i stood up too
late and forgot to wash i wake up and
i'm like i love the way my eyes look
it's actually sexy a little smudgy yeah
yeah it's a little rock and roll a
little cool bad girl yeah
that's when you're the [ __ ]
[Applause]
squeaky queen
all right ross your story thank you
gabrielle thank you
okay
i cannot wait to get your thoughts on
this one because speaking of keeping the
magic alive there's one married couple
from new jersey who's been doing it for
40 years now but how
by scheduling their fights the atlantic
reports liz cutler and tom cruise swear
by the system they schedule a
disagreement meeting once every three
months and in between they keep a
running list
of all their grievances with their
partner and when they finally come to
the table they've got some ground rules
one they don't shut the other person
down if another one says it's a problem
it's a problem they accept the fact that
change will come but it might be in baby
steps and experts saying that some
distance can help people cool down and
having a date helps force people who
have a conflict actually talk about it
but
here's the dilemma for me right if
you're scheduling every three months
we're going to sit down and hash things
out are you holding it in for all that
time are you spending that time
collecting evidence about oh i don't
like this about you i don't like this
about you but i'm going to keep it in
and let it boil and then on august 8th
we're going at it hi
i don't know
i
okay i love this i have learned recently
in the last few years when i've come at
situations
even five minutes later
i'm not as hot i'm coming in a little
calmer a little more rational
then give it a day or two sometimes i'm
like you know i don't even care anymore
right i'm gonna let that go
so i'm not hating it ross i'll tell you
here's the deal i think you address
little fires and then yes a state of the
union meeting once a month would be
really good but if you're going to
schedule that you should also be
scheduling other things like date nights
sex something fun something you're not
dreading all month long can we have a
little fun please too
in the meantime well ross um one month
today
um from one month today i think you and
i should come with our notebook oh
um and i'm gonna need another notebook
no okay i'm kidding
i'm kidding i love you i know raise of
hands who would do this uh every three
months raise the polls raise your polls
green for i would do this red for no way
and heck
oh my god it is overwhelmingly red yeah
well we'll talk about this drew in about
three months all right one month one
month okay
[Music]